herzlich willkommen zu meinem Vortrag
lernen als Handeln in der Zeit von dem
was ist zu dem was bleibt der Beitrag
den ich zum diesjährigen Symposium Zeit
in der Hochschullehre leisten möchte
basiert ganz stark auf meiner eigenen
lehr- und Lernerfahrung ich unterrichte
Philosophie an der Fernuni Hagen in Form
von online und Präsenzlehre mit einer
Gruppengröße bis zu 30 Personen das ist
sozusagen der Rahmen von meiner Lehre
und begleitet werden diese Lehrangebote
mit Studienbriefen welche die
Studierenden passen zu ihrem jeweiligen
Modulen in den Bachelor oder auch im
Masterstudium zur Verfügung gestellt
bekommen das sind schriftliche
Studienbriefe die bekommen Sie entweder
als PDF oder sogar noch in Print und die
erfüllen einen ja eine vergleichbare
Funktion wie die Vorlesungen an präsenz-
gebeten also sie bieten einen
orientierenden Überblick des jeweiligen
wissensgebiets des vorgestellt wird und
die Seminare stehen zwar in einem
thematischen Zusammenhang damit
behandeln jedoch meist spezifischere
Perspektiven da geht es dann sozusagen
nicht um was ist Erkenntnistheorie
sondern man liest ein Werk von einem
Autor dass sich diesem Thema widmet also
in unserem Fach der Philosophie geht es
insbesondere um die Auseinandersetzung
mit primärlektüre und die zielgerichtete
Diskussion darüber das erlaubt eine hohe
Individualität in der Ausgestaltung des
Studiums man kann wählen in welchen
historischen Abschnitt in welcher
Autoren und Autorinnen in welche Methode
man sich einarbeiten möchte
für mich als Studentin war das zum einen
großartig weil ein ganzer wissenskosmos
jedes Semester vor einem neu
ausgebreitet wird und aufgeht und man da
jedes mal frische Entdeckerlust bekommt
aber auf der anderen Seite war es auch
immer eine große und wichtige Frage für
mich wie ich diese verschiedenen
Informationen zu einem Gesamtbild
integrieren kann und ich habe mich oft
gefragt wo stehe ich wo will ich hin was
fehlt mir dazu noch die Vorlesungen und
Seminare waren zwar immer für sich
interessant aber auch voneinander
abgetrennte wissensräume und
mittlerweile weiß ich wie wichtig das
wiederholen und vernetzen das ist auch
heute schon ganz oft vorgekommen von
Informationen für das Gedächtnis ist und
auch dafür sein fachbezogenes
Selbstvertrauen durch eine stabile
Wissensbasis zu festigen
Vernetzung des Gelernten ist also keine
private oder individuell begründete
Herausforderung Herausforderung
lediglich meines Studiums sondern
allgemein für die Lehre und das Lernen
an der Hochschule relevant deswegen
möchte ich meinen Vortrag dazu nutzen
auf diesen wichtigen Übergang im Lernen
als Handeln in der Zeit von dem was ist
zu dem was bleibt bewusst zu machen um
ihn auch bewusst gestalten zu können
und mein Vortrag
teilt sich in zwei Abschnitte auf zu
Beginn möchte ich theoretische vor
Überlegungen skizzieren die erklären
können wieso diese von mir ins Zentrum
gestellte zeitliche orientierungsweise
für das Lernen wichtig ist
bevor ich dann zweitens meine Vorschläge
für eine praktische Umsetzung formuliere
die dazu beitragen können bereits in der
Lehre diese Art Verknüpfung zu fördern
genau also ich beginne mit meinen
theoretischen Impulsen in erziehungs-
und bildungswissenschaftlicher
Perspektive ist Zeit eine inhärente
ordnungskategorie von Lernen und
Bildungsprozessen überhaupt eine wie ich
finde sehr treffende Metapher für die
Bedeutung des Zeithorizonts unseres
lernen
im biografischen Zusammenhang hat die
bildungswissenschaftler Entschuldigung
bildungswissenschaftlerin Bettina dausin
formuliert und ich möchte sie kurz
Vorlesen das ist wenn sie an den Vortrag
von Jörg Noller denken diese qualitativ
subjektive
Perspektive auf Zeit ich zitiere das
Leben ist eine Baustelle und lernen ist
ein konstruktiver Prozess in dem aus
Handlungen und Erlebnissen Erfahrungen
und Sinn produziert werden
welcher biografische Sinn welche
wissenskonfigurationen entstehen hängt
zum einen von dem Material und den
Werkzeugen ab die auf der jeweiligen
Baustelle verfügbar sind zum anderen von
dem Möglichkeitsraum für konkretes
Handeln für erstmaliges erproben und
immer wieder Neues versuchen
für Fehler Abänderungen und neue
Entwürfe schließlich auch von dem
kommunikativen Raum für individuelles
und gemeinsames reflektieren
die Metapher der Baustelle für das Leben
gibt einen ersten allgemeinen Rahmen für
das was ich mit Lernen als Handeln in
der Zeit meine als Prozess hat diese
Baustelle eine Vergangenheit eine
Gegenwart und eine Zukunft und damit
zeigen sich drei mögliche zeitliche
orientierungsweisen zu biografischen
Gestaltung des Lebens
Regina Mikula und Reinhard Lechner haben
sich der Zeitlichkeit in biografischen
Lernprozessen ausführlich gewidmet und
beschreiben die gegenwartsorientierung
als konkretes wahrnehmen agieren und
reagieren im zeitlich örtlichen jetzt
und hier
die vergangenheitsorientierung bedeutet
eine Orientierung an eigener und
kollektiver Erinnerung und Historie
während Zukunftsorientierung mit dem
erwägen von Entscheidungen sowie deren
Auswirkungen auf mögliche Ziele
zusammenhängt
vielleicht lässt sich diese Art Metapher
auch auf das Studium als biografische
Lebensphase übertragen das würde
bedeuten dass alle unsere Studierenden
ihre eigenen Baustellen mit ins Seminar
bringen als Lehrende stellen wir
gewissermaßen das Material zur Verfügung
damit der Bau am Wissensgebäude
weitergehen kann geben aber zudem auch
ein Möglichkeitsraum dafür
auszuprobieren welche Eigenschaften des
Material mit sich bringt welche
Werkzeuge sich besonders zu Verarbeitung
eignen und wir bieten einen
kommunikativen Raum um die Bau
Fortschritte sowie die baulichen
Herausforderungen gemeinsam und
individuell zu reflektieren
sich also einen Überblick zu verschaffen
damit die Bauleitung auch stets aktiv
dabei ist und sich gewisse
baustellenanteile nicht
verselbstständigen dieser von dasin
angesprochene kommunikative Raum
bedeutet für mich einen Ort an an dem
die Reflexion von dem was ist zudem was
bleibt stattfinden kann
das heißt wir konzentrieren uns auf das
was ist das was wir gerade im Seminar
tun und versuchen es für unsere
Baustelle anschlussfähig zu machen indem
wir es mit bereits gebauten verbinden um
an etwas zu arbeiten das bleibt
dieses reflektieren verbindet die
Gegenwart also mein aktuelles werkeln
auf der Baustelle mit der Vergangenheit
also das auf was ich aufbauen kann und
der Zukunft der Ausrichtung also den
Plan an welchen Gebäude ich überhaupt
baue
neben dieser allgemeinen Perspektive auf
sinnproduktion in Lernprozessen möchte
ich noch eine zweite theoretische
Vorannahme anführen um die Bedeutung des
Übergangs von dem was ist zu dem was
bleibt zu plausibilisieren
und zwar möchte ich an eine gut
erforschte basisannahme aus der
psychologischen Lernforschung erinnern
die Unterscheidung des Langzeit von
Kurzzeitgedächtnis auf die Gerhard Roth
zum Beispiel für eine Verbesserung des
Lernens hingewiesen hat ich zitiere aus
einer Reihe von experimentellen Befunden
schließt man das bei jedem Lernvorgang
Inhalte eines frühen kurzzeitigen
Gedächtnisses in Inhalte eines späten
langzeitigen Gedächtnisses überführt
oder konsolidiert werden
diese Konsolidierungsphase ist beim
Menschen mit der mitunter auch bewussten
Wiederholungen des lerninhalts zum
Beispiel stilles aufsagen einer neuen
Telefonnummer verbunden
die von Rot hier verwendete
Begrifflichkeit lässt sich wunderbar an
die gerade besprochene Metapher
anschließen der Begriff konsolidieren
leitet sich etymologisch aus dem
Lateinischen solidare ab und bedeutet
dicht machen festmachen befestigen und
wir wissen alle wie wichtig Stabilität
und Festigkeit für den Erhalt von
Bauwerken
auch wenn das Wiederholen oftmals eher
negativ mit dem intellektuell wenig
erfrischenden auswendig lernen in
Verbindung gebracht wird wir haben es
auch vorher schon in dem Vortrag der
beiden Kollegen gehört
dass die studieren nicht begeistert
waren als die wiederholungssessions
eingeleitet wurden
ich darauf zu reduzieren vielmehr stellt
es eine für unser Gedächtnis und in
Wissensaufbau ganz zentrale Funktion da
diese kommt auch zum Ausdruck wenn wir
uns auf den Kern von kognitiven
Lernstrategien konzentrieren die gerade
zum Einprägen von neuem Wissen geeignet
sind also für das um was es in Seminaren
an der Hochschule vornehmlich geht
neben dem Organisieren dem elaborieren
und dem kritischen prüfen stellt das
Wiederholen eine der vier
grundsätzlichen Arbeitstechniken da das
wiederholen ist die Lernstrategie die
ich für die nun kommenden Vorschläge für
die Jahre konzentrieren werde und ich
hoffe ich kann sie davon überzeugen dass
dies sich nicht in langweiligen Lähmung
Techniken vollziehen muss wie wir es
vielleicht noch vom Vokabeln lernen aus
unserer eigenen Schulzeit oder dem
Studium kennen
ich habe jetzt im Folgenden mich auch
das Seminar als Zeitlinie konzentriert
also sehen links in Seminar beginnen mit
der ersten Sitzung und dann eben die
Abschluss Sitzung rechts mit dem Fall
der ja noch weiter geht weil das Studium
ist ja nicht zu Ende und um diese
Verknüpfung soll es ja auch gehen
und die ersten Beispiele die ich bringen
möchte dienen sich vor allen Dingen für
den Seminar beginnen und es gibt noch
eine zweitliche zeitliche
ordnungskategorie die sie jetzt nicht
erkennen können auf der Folie ich habe
bin immer von wenig zeitlichen Aufwand
zu mehr zeitlichen Aufwand gegangen in
meiner Liste also das Vorwissen zu
aktivieren das wurde heute auch schon
angesprochen dass es das was ich
sozusagen für das Wiederholen zu Beginn
nutze und wenn man wenig Zeit zur
Verfügung hat von der Präsenzzeit dann
kann man das durch asynchrone Lernphasen
aus den Sitzungen in Präsenz oder auch
in live online Sessions
ausschließen und schon im Vorfeld
integrieren
oder das braucht schon ein bisschen mehr
Zeit von der synchronen Zeit die einem
zur Verfügung stellt man verknüpft es
mit der Vorstellungsrunde oder das wäre
jetzt sehr viel Zeit die dafür in
Anspruch genommen wird man veranstaltet
ein think per share was sozusagen jetzt
hier gemacht wird ist wie konzentrieren
uns auf die Vergangenheit wir
bedienen uns der Quelle unserer eigenen
Erinnerung und die Beispiele die ich
Ihnen da mitbringen kann ist einmal das
ist jetzt relativ klein das sehen Sie
unten dieses ja Fronti speeds aus einem
Buch aus dem 18 Jahrhundert
das war eine Moodle Lernumgebung die ich
zu meinem Seminar aufgebaut habe und es
war die Gelegenheit aufgrund dieses
Bilderrätsels in das Thema Aufklärung
einzusteigen also es ging darum sich zu
das wurde begleitet mit Fragen die ich
formuliert habe sich darauf zu
konzentrieren was weiß ich denn schon zu
dem Thema wie kann ich vielleicht diesen
Bildausschnitt einordnen und ich habe
dann für die erste Sitzung diesen
Ausgangspunkt gehabt um in das Thema
einzusteigen das zweite was dann schon
in die Sitzung integriert wurde das ist
hier eine Folie das war ein
Online-Seminar da konnte man sich über
die Zoom-Funktion des Stempelns verorten
auf einer Skala wie viel Vorwissen man
denn mitbringt zu dem Autor den wir
gelesen haben das erkannt in dem Fall
und ich habe dann dieses Stempeln
benutzt damit in der vorstellungs
Sekunde noch mal genauer darauf
eingegangen wird welche Texte man schon
gelesen hat welches Seminare man
vielleicht sogar besucht hat oder was
man denn vielleicht für Interessen hat
warum man sie denn jetzt sozusagen
schließen möchte die Lücke falls sie
dann da ist und das was sie oben sehen
das war das Ergebnis von einem sehr
umfangreichen Zink per share also da
ging es um das mal ein Workshop und es
geht um das philosophische schreiben in
dem Fall und es gab zuerst eine kurze
reflexionszeit für die einzelnen
Studierenden um sich zu erinnern was
sind denn die eigenen Erfahrungen die
schon da sind dann eine
Gruppendiskussion in einzelnen Breakout
Sessions und da wurden die Ergebnisse
dann in dieses Tablet eingetragen und
wir haben wirklich darüber diskutiert
das ist natürlich etwas was zeitlich
einen sehr großen Umfang einnimmt
dann für das Seminar selbst um den
Wissensaufbau zu unterstützen
da habe ich ganz gute Erfahrungen
gemacht auch mit asynchronen angeboten
also ich begleite jedes Seminar
mittlerweile egal ob online oder Präsenz
mit einer Module Lernumgebung das ist
auch dazu da dass man sich sozusagen mit
den anderen vernetzen kann wir sind hier
im Fernstudium das ist immer noch mal
besonders wichtig dass man auch die
Gelegenheit hat in den Austausch zu
kommen und da leite ich zu
Schreibübungen an also wenn wir
sozusagen ein Thema abgeschlossen haben
dann kann man da noch eine Schreibübung
einreichen oder man wird auch nur man
bekommt nur den Vorschlag das ist dann
wieder etwas was nicht von der live-zeit
abgeht was sozusagen
etwas ist was ich selber noch nicht
ausprobiert habe das sind Protokolle und
Quiz ist die sind aber schon integriert
in die Seminar Sitzungen das mit den
quizzes finde ich ganz spannend aber das
ist was was ich in der Philosophie noch
nicht so wirklich anwenden konnte also
wenn sie da Erfahrungen haben im
geisteswissenschaftlichen Bereich dann
sehr gerne und das andere ist das
gemeinsame wiederholen dass ich mit
einer methodenvorstellung verknüpfe sie
sehen hier wird sozusagen der Fokus auf
die Gegenwart gerichtet also das was wir
im Seminar gerade tun auch unser agieren
und reagieren die Beispiele die ich in
da mitbringen kann das ist hier unten
links
ein Ausschnitt aus dieser Nudeln lernen
Umgebung mit einer Schreibaufgabe das
war damals das Höhlengleichnis von
Platon und das Angebot auch diese
sozusagen mit einem Feedback zu versehen
das kann dann zusätzlich eingereicht
werden
auf weiter rechts sehen Sie einen
Ausschnitt über ein Lernvideo das ich
erstellt habe und das gibt sozusagen
Tipps wie man denn generell das Seminar
nutzen kann um vom Lernen ins Schreiben
zu kommen das ist also vom Lesen ins
Schreiben zu kommen das ist gerade bei
uns in der Philosophie wichtig weil wir
ja im Seminar sehr viel sprechen aber
unsere Prüfungsform meistens die
Hausarbeit oder die Klausur ist also
etwas Schriftliches und das ist dann
tatsächlich nur eine Erinnerung für die
Studierenden was sie alles tun können
das wäre zum Beispiel dieses Jahr
Minute gesehen haben dass man wirklich
kurz nach dem Seminar gleich den ersten
Gedanken festhält was war für mich jetzt
gerade wichtig was habe ich neu dazu
gelernt dann möchte ich vielleicht noch
mal vertieft drauf schauen und wenn das
im Präsenzseminar ist dann kann man das
wunderbar auf dem Rückweg machen in der
U-Bahn oder S-Bahn
oder eben bei einem Online Seminar man
klappt den Laptop zu und schreibt sich
das kurz auf und dann hat man schon eine
Basis auf die man wieder aufbauen kann
wenn es dann darum geht eine
Fragestellung für die Hausarbeit zu
finden
und was sie oben sehen diese zentralen
Bestandteile einer Argumentation das ist
dann der integrationsversuch von mir
dass ich nicht bloß wiederhole was wir
sozusagen sachlich inhaltlich
kennengelernt haben in den Sitzungen
davor sondern ich verbinde das mit
Methoden die für uns als Philosophen und
Philosophen und wichtig sind hier jetzt
zum Beispiel mit den
Bestandteilen einer Argumentation ja
also ich habe dann nicht mehr nur diese
Wiederholung von den Texten aber eben
auch sondern
praktiziere gewissermaßen wie wir uns
als Philosophen Philosophen in diesen
Texten widmen können und rufe
methodische Kompetenz bei meinen
Studierenden ins Gedächtnis und das
macht diese Wiederholung dann auch ein
bisschen interessanter als wenn wir uns
jetzt nur auf die Inhalte konzentrieren
wird
und dann für das Ende für den Abschluss
der Sitzung das habe ich jetzt
abschließende Konsolidierung genannt da
wollen wir uns noch mal drauf
konzentrieren was denn eigentlich die
Baustelle für uns ist also was nehmen
wir denn aus dem Seminar jetzt mit
konkret für unser Studium und da gibt es
auch wieder so ein Vorschlag für die
asynchrone
Herangehensweise nämlich eine Mindmap
oder wissensbilder zu erstellen
man kann so ähnlich wie bei der
Vorstellungsrunde das ganze mit einem
Feedback oder einer Evaluation verbinden
die dann zwar nicht konkret die eigenen
Pläne beinhaltet aber schon dazu
übergeht zu sagen ja was habe ich denn
jetzt eigentlich hier mitgenommen und
warum und was fehlt mir noch ja dass man
die Studierenden sensibilisiert wo sie
vielleicht auch selber weitermachen
können
und das was dann relativ viel Zeit
einnehmen würde das wäre ein sogenannter
Think Tank als Abschlussdiskussion da
habe ich dann auch noch mal jeweils
Beispiele aus meiner eigenen Lehrpraxis
also für die
wissensbilder da das war auch wieder in
der Moodle Lernumgebung eine Übung die
ich sozusagen zur Verfügung gestellt
habe und ich habe aber selbst ein
Vorschlag gemacht und habe sozusagen
diese Wiederholung übernommen zum
Schluss also selbst vorgenommen und
wollte damit aber dazu anregen dass man
eben auch noch andere Möglichkeiten hat
sich das ganze vielleicht mal zu
visualisieren und wirklich kreativ zu
werden und es war ganz ganz
es wurde ganz gut angenommen von meinen
Studierenden genau
dann das mit der Feedback und der
evaluationsrunde sehen Sie hier unten
links das war einfach eine schnelle
Umfrage über Zoom die ich da gemacht
habe also es war für mich als lernende
wichtig zu wissen was denn jetzt
hilfreich überhaupt für diese konkrete
Fragestellung und dann habe ich eben mit
Freitext gearbeitet für besonders
gefallen hat mir und künftig würde ich
mir zusätzlich wünschen so und so sie
sehen die sind doppelten Effekt ich
bekomme eine wichtige Rückmeldung zu dem
wie ich fortfolgen diese
Lehrveranstaltung verbessern könnte und
die Studierenden haben einen kleinen
Moment der Besinnung und können sagen ja
so soll es eigentlich weitergehen oder
das fehlt mir noch
und für den Think Tank das ist dann
etwas was sehr viel Raum eingenommen hat
das war unsere ganze abschlussssitzung
da haben wir unsere Forschungsfrage
aufgegriffen und gemeinsam wirklich
rekapituliert anhand der gelesenen Texte
wie wir jetzt dazu Stellung beziehen
würden und haben diese stimmen dann über
den Chat eingesammelt und zu einem
Gesamtbild integriert das war dann aber
eine ganze
Powerpoint-Präsentation und die konnte
dann jeder in der Mode lernen Umgebung
im Anschluss sich auch noch mal
runterladen und hatte das sozusagen groß
zusammengefasst
genau das war sozusagen mein Beitrag
meine Kleine Überlegung zur Zeit in der
Hochschullehre und ich danke Ihnen sehr
fürs Zuhören ich bin sehr gespannt zu
erfahren was sie davon halten und wie
sie Wiederholungen bisher in ihre
Lehrveranstaltungen integrieren